Jen I believe you like to boil down
story structure into four parts trigger
dilemma choice and pursuit
I I've had so many different components
of the looking at stories so it's all
about different angles so yes that is
one formula that I've used and I've also
used the idea of another
uh four points that I've used is the
idea of a biggest fear dream
and the trigger event and the Dilemma
and so looking at how those things
affect story
we always hear about three-act structure
yes why do you break story into four
parts
I am always seeking Story tools so I
analyze story
and the Brilliance of what is being done
right now in film and in streaming I am
always looking for tools and how do I
break it down in a way that the writer
understands and of course obviously when
you look at the 3x structure you're also
looking at act two is in two parts so
you're essentially looking at four parts
of the story so
and I think that there are you never
know like what comes through you where
you hit these aha moments when you're
watching story and you're like all right
these are the points that work uh I
remember recently
I was looking for uh components key
points that take us into voice
and I read a pilot where the voice was
so clear and I hit the aha moment of
looking at the concept
the uh main conflict
and how the protagonists feels about
that concept
uh conflict and when I looked at those
in in the title in the case of this
pilot was the title the concept the main
conflict and the characters expression
of how they felt
that for me was like all right this is
voice this is what voice is we know
why the writer is telling the story
through
understanding these connecting points
and we feel the voice of the writer
through the central character and how
that Central character feels about the
main conflict
and so voice doesn't necessarily mean
first person narrative it could be told
third person and we can still feel a
strong voice oh absolutely absolutely
there are so I yes their voice is felt
in so many different ways and and voice
even you can feel you can feel voice in
the action lines you can feel it you
know I've seen Writers Do prose in the
action lines where you have an inanimate
object have a personality trait and
suddenly you're bringing in an inanimate
object to life where the audience can
feel it voice is there versus whether
it's the third person whether it's the
first person understanding
something in the depth of the character
that gives you a sense of why the writer
is writing the story and what is this
story really about
so like uh in Wednesday Adams the hand
yes has its own voice and its own
exactly the hand is symbolic of so much
that show I and I've only seen a few
episodes but that show is so brilliant
because I was trying to think
I thought I like the film uh top gun
Maverick you have a built-in audience
because we knew so first going into
Wednesday you you are looking and you
have a built-in audience from The Adams
Family then your your grounding it with
the idea of a character who feels like
an outcast going to a boarding school
for outcasts and continues to feel on
the outside looking in and that is so
encompassing so much of what's going on
in the pandemic that I feel like it's
hitting a note and because we feel like
we know this character but we don't know
this character at the depth that this
show is bringing us into this character
so that it has an immediate audience
finding following as well as I think old
generation and New Generation finding a
value in this story and and everything
that's going on in the world making us
feel that value and then you look at top
gun Maverick and you're like all right
everybody saw the first Top Gun and you
are we are all in that wound I mean we
felt the wound with what happens to use
in that movie so that is something that
has stayed with us and then you have
this film which is phenomenal
take us into going beyond that through
Goose's son and Maverick being put in a
new dilemma where the past since we were
all in it is haunting him an affecting
choice in the new so that was an
incredible way to look at how do I get
an audience by finding an audience who
knows the wound because and even if they
miss that movie is still going to find
fulfillment from looking at this but
chances are most people have seen the
first movie before going into the second
movie so so I look at both those
projects and I I
I look in awe at how the thinking went
into and how the outcome is is amazing
is three-act story structure a rule that
you can break
it is it is you are it is it's not a
rule that anyone recommends breaking it
is there to help you when I look at rule
breaking with writers I look at
certainly I feel like in streaming
rules are being broken
all over the place
they're being broken or in film with
Aaron Sorkin or they're being broken
by seasoned writers
you know when when you have a seasoned
writer break a rule
because of the confidence they have and
understanding story and transformation
and the Arc of growth and story is
coming through them in a way that maybe
doesn't add here to 3x or what it's
supposed to be
there's a there's a value as long as a
writer knows what they're doing and and
the the 3x structure is has a purpose
the 3x structure works
however
uh there are so many brilliant things
being done and said that
could be
turning it on its head a little bit here
and there and some of it is working and
some of I would say the majority of it
is failing but there are certain moments
that are working because of the seasoned
writer or
even if the writer isn't seasoned but
they have something to say that we feel
rules can be broken